morad el hattab géopolitologue bonsoir
morad el hattab merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur arte france emmanuel
macron qui vient donc de s'exprimer à
l'issue de cette journée le président de
la république qui dénonce je cite le jeu
hégémonique de puissance en méditerranée
site en russie et turquie
que doit-on comprendre bellemare lui
attentisme stratégique en tant qu il n'a
aucune crédibilité
excusez moi de vous le dire puisque
quand bien même j'ai des points d'accord
avec le président tueur sur la question
de la libye et sur la question de la
basilique sainte-sophie historiquement
pour être honnête y sont si proches de
la turquie sont un non sens
géostratégique un non sens diplomatique
c'est un nid de crise diplomatique tout
le monde sait que la turquie fera 3 km
de ses côtes
la zone économique et musique turque est
hypothéquée par la présence de ces îles
grecques et au lieu de se comporter
comme le fait actuellement le président
de la république française
il devrait permettre une entente
possible réfléchi entre un partage
équitable sur les ressources
énergétiques entre la grèce et la
turquie
mais en taxant de prime abord les turcs
comme étant plus des partenaires
monsieur macro et hors jeu et comme vous
l'avez rappelé ça reste une rencontre
informelle le restaurant formel alors ça
c'était avant le sommet effectivement la
france qui disait qu'il ne considérait
plus la turquie comme des partenaires il
n'empêche
à l'issue de ce sommet la discussion
apaisant peut-être un petit peu les
choses des pays du monde cette affirmé
il voulait rien engagé un dialogue de
bonne foi avec la turquie nous a dit
emmanuel macron est ce que vous croyez
ce dialogue de bonne foi encore possible
écoutez je suis un garçon si j'enclenche
un dialogue avec quelqu'un je commence
pas par l'insulté pas un bon jeu dire ce
rétropédalage parce que quelques
peut-être que quelques-uns de ses
conseillers de l'ombre nous ont avertis
de la réponse
du ministre affaires étrangères turc qui
l'a taxé d' arrogant et c'est d'ailleurs
peut-être ce qu'il a vu son comportement
moi je suis vraiment décontenancé par le
manque de crédit que la france a de plus
en plus dès que monsieur meunier macron
prend la parole lors je comprends qu'ils
recherchent le statut rhin toujours été
tendre envers l'europe et notamment la
france à linverse il faut il faut
remettre les choses à leur place quand
même je vous répond franchement
l'attitude de jj plein de points de
désaccord avec monsieur erdogan
mais pour le coup il agit de manière
souveraine je veux pas me répéter ces
îles c'est un non sens géostratégique il
farah 3 km de ses côtes
on a l'impression que les navires turcs
les forages dur se font plein milieu de
la méditerranée ce n'est pas le cas et
c'est ça qu'il faut remettre en place
les turcs économiquement ne vont pas
accepter de serre à six y ait par des
pays environnants
alors que à trois kilomètres de leurs
côtes ils ont largement du gaz pour
devenir autosuffisants alors
qu'aujourd'hui on exporte 90 ça
n'apporte du 90 % c'est de la logique
mais monsieur macro ne peut pas
comprendre les logiques souveraine et
comme il ya des graves problèmes en
interne
il essaie de jouer de la stature
internationale mais il faut qu'il arrête
il passe son temps à insulter tous les
dirigeants étrangers
et je rappelle il ya pas qu emmanuel
macron mourad et le tabac il ya les sept
pays qui étaient présents qui ce soir
clairement c'est l'une des annonces à
l'issue de ce sommet soutiendrait des
sanctions économiques supplémentaires
contre la turquie si celle ci je cite
persisté dans ses actions unilatérales
en méditerranée
orientale votre réaction ils ne sont pas
fondées elles faire c'est une forme
d'ingérence complètement mais attendez
vous dites que sept pays un intérêt à
nantes
bonjour on se parle il n'y a que l'armée
grecque et l'armée française sur zone
les six autres les cinq autres pays que
nous venons d'évoquer
on logique tout autre aujourd'hui
suivent emmanuel macron aux pasties
hilton du poing sur la table ne pas
sortir d'un échec par rapport à cette
réunion informelle mais encore une fois
et le maniema kron dans ses réponses
n'est pas à la hauteur des enjeux
je vous signale que sur la question de
la libye qu'elle est censée être au
coeur de cette réunion
qu'est ce qu'il en est sorti rien sur la
question des migrants
rien sur la question du covin rien il
fait une fixation sur la turbie les
services de nous coûter très cher je
vous dis encore une fois je suis en
désaccord profond avec la turquie sur la
libye sur la basilique sainte sophie
mais pour ce qui est de deux forages
turcs en mer méditerranée
vous savez comme moi qu historiquement
c'est un non sens et jour stratégique et
diplomatique
c'est un nid à crise diplomatique ces
histoires d'îles grecques donc tout le
monde est au courant et emmanuel macron
de se comporter en chef d'état il faut
qu'il cesse absolument de s'ingérer
partout il a été le valais du fmi au
liban en orient l'a très mal pris
il s'est comporté de manière odieuse
avec loukachenko odieuse avec vladimir
poutine dans la sphère navalni qui est
un opposant pays par des puissances
étrangères dont d'ailleurs donald trump
a dit qu'on n'a toujours pas trouvé le
poison de son empoisonnement donc et que
monsieur macron s'occupe des affaires
internes
il ya beaucoup à faire en france s'ils
commencent sérieusement à agacer tout le
monde
merci morad el hattab d'avoir été avec
nous pour nous apporter votre point de
vue après
ce sommet un médecin qui a eu lieu en
corse où je cite emmanuel macron a
dénoncé le jeu hégémonique de puissance
en méditerranée citant la russie et la
turquie
le médecin qui se dit favorable à de
nouvelles sanctions économiques si la
turquie
poursuivez ces élections unilatérales en
méditerranée orientale